hello there reject nation it is time for the
ultimate easter egg breakdown from new rockstars
as eric voss apparently 170 easter eggs have
been discovered now the digital release for no
way home is out there's always going to be more
to unpack about this movie always decades worth
realistically it's probably the last spider-man
no way home video we do for a little while
two days without spider-man no well what would
we ever do with ourselves there were weeks or you
guys are like well they haven't talked about
spider-man for weeks and then one week we're
like we're doing a bunch again here we are that's
what everyone wants is to relive 2021 over again
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric voss
and spider-man no way home is now available
in higher resolution and now that i can actually
pause and look at the stuff instead of begging
the amc projectionist to freeze the frame i know
that's you back sure in this movie that we just
gotta re-break down this film some of this will
be stuff that i found on my first breakdown on
release weekend which has grown to be my most
viewed video ever thank you wow so much so to
show my gratitude to you and to the talented
artists who worked on this film i have found
well over 100 more details like my final tally
is close to 200 then i am going to present to you
comprehensive near shot-by-shot analysis of
everything great about spider-man no way home i'll
never need to watch this again make it less about
my commentary now that we've all seen the film
okay over the studio titles we actually hear
mysterio's audio from the post-credits scene
of spider-man far from home i managed to send the
elemental back to the dimensional riff but i don't
think i'm gonna make it off this bridge alive
in his dying moments mysterio maintained the lie
of his illusions coming from an interdimensional
rift all the doom peter parker but also ironically
actual threats yeah risks become the actual
crisis in this movie the marvel studios title
card has been updated so that on the r replacing
rocket is peter's portal arrival in england
the way this movie will bring back other peters
through the same kinds of portals far from home
of course ended with the credits cutting off
peter's f-bomb here a car horn censors it
the scene has been recreated almost exactly down
to the three extras behind mj dressed just like
the guys behind her in the 2019 scene the even
game the dude with the phone wired earbuds just
like he had before attention to detail those lucky
sons of [ __ ] right there can you imagine that
you're just a background player and now you're
like hey come back to be a co-star we need you
the script supervisor demands it we're even gonna
give you a speaking line my man how cool is that
absolutely all those years later that's nuts them
and seriously the script supervisor deserves all
the credit because those are the details they got
to keep the most track give it up for scripts and
revisers skip supervisors that's right but the
main difference of course is that mj now wears the
broken black dahlia necklace that peter bought for
her in venice and gave to her in london to which
she said sorry it's broken i actually like it
better broken mj knows things can never be perfect
her mantra is expect disappointment and you will
never get disappointed and that is why she refuses
to let peter say i love you in order to leave
things broken and give him a reason to find her
one onlooker asks you're just a kid i nodded that
onlooker on the train at sam rainey spider-man 2
in 2004 when toby mcguire was unmasked he's just
a kid just a kid that peter's exposure was met
with gratitude leaving him with faith in humanity
but this peter's exposure is met with hostility
leaving him more cynical as they swing through the
city they pass billboards for rogers and musical
which we saw in hawkeye and will return in secret
invasion there are also billboards for fortnight
and the hyundai bionic five which did a cross
promotional campaign with the film its slogan
electrify your journey of course tying in with
electro there's also a participation billboard
because sony i love that that's how they got their
product placement in there they want so badly to
be a part of the movie itself oh my god they're
like you'll see it for like point five seconds
if you pay really really close attention that
equates to thousands of ps5 sales and audi sales
these screens show peter's face with this mask
covering half of it a recurring image that we've
seen in the comics they land on queensborough
bridge with the nearby roosevelt island tramway
the same location as the final showdown in the
2002 film they dropped past flash on his phone
is a tick tock feed of the daily bugle official
the account hosted by betty brant leading up to
the film's release they pop out in front
of del mar's deli now labeled del mars 3
as this is the third film in this trilogy and
we have seen this bodega destroyed at least once
the sign reads best sandwiches in queens
calling back mr del mar's line in homecoming
the best sandwiches in queens and they are coming
out of the sewer actually because in queens the
subway turns into an elevated train as you see in
the background john watts details of the manhole
cover and since throughout these opening minutes
we're getting a ton of shout outs to the past
eras this has got to be a callback to the closing
shot of the amazing spiderman they land outside
oh my god to help her and peter accidentally
grabs her butt and then immediately says i'm sorry
i never noticed that walking in on peter shirtless
with homecoming mj hands peter his i survived my
trip to nyc shirt that he wore in homecoming
also in this apartment his poster for the feast
fundraiser where spiderman made his appearance and
far from home john watts directed the sequence in
one two minute long take two minutes long
in which tom holland and zadea impressively
scramble around this place when peter whips
the first shade shut the animators made sure to
show that webbing shooting out of his arm in his
reflection in the cabinet and when the last shade
shoots back up it looks like tom might actually
improvise webbing it shut in order to keep it down
i think what's so cool about that one shot too
is that not only does it emphasize the comedic
hijinks but it really emphasizes the tension
as well oh yeah so you get the best of both
worlds the comedy plus the suspense and just
wrapped in this beautiful blanket this tortilla
of enjoyment is that right watson this is
tortilla yeah yeah rye watson yeah what's copper
or todd or whichever all the cats love
spiderman cat cats there's a lot of cats
here you got a lot of cats j jones jameson's
graphic shows protester signs calling for
peter to be locked up another calling him
a criminal with devil horns this awkward
photo of peter's actually there's a criminal
photo that we saw in the far from home deleted
scene and then over on the far right is a sign
reading it was better when you were blipped wow
trio of terror front page as well as an us weekly
that compares mj to liz holy [ __ ] from the
academic decathlon of dc in homecoming another
headline reports mysterio douses hydro man in
venice because in far from home they initially
thought the elemental in venice was the longtime
spidey villain hydra man morris bench god damn
it's it's videos like this that remind you why
new rock stars is amazing right finding these
production design details that otherwise would
have never been celebrated properly 99.9 of
people are not gonna notice this at all and
you have to have that amazing cia technology to
go zoom enhance in order to understand what it
is you're dealing with somewhere out there a set
dresser is watching this video with a single tear
rolling down their face with andrea
buchelli's time to say goodbye
jameson also has some spare bottles of his
supplements throughout the place showing
how his whole new fancy studio the whole business
was really paid for by those pills the daily news
front page has photoshopped peter mj and ned using
their yearbook photos and for the first time we
see mj's last name watson making michelle jones
watson the variant of mary jane watson of this
universe time magazine calls peter iron man junior
how did that teenager become tony stark's heir
apparent all this echoing the same sentiments of
team mysterio from far from home as if this could
have been headlined that they scripted for the
media peter gets coated in green paint this is
actually from a deleted scene with tom holland's
brother harry holland you'll notice the graffiti
behind peter reads ramos for embarrassing matt
rabbos spider-man comic artist who partnered
with dan slott international news is a ticker
reporting interpol issues arrest warrant for czech
republic's night monkey showing how your people
are still unsure if spider-man and night monkey
for far from home are the same person like the
narrative that spider-man protects new york but
sometimes europe yeah absolutely and then
if also if he ever gets in trouble again
he can always fall back on that night monkey
persona you know that's true but then he would
need the night monkey outfit from the avengers
people that's right no one would know who he is
sorry europe sorry europe you're screwed you
don't have spider-man anymore all you got is
the the ability to walk around naked or whatever
it is you freaks do freaks or americans and then
political turmoil continues in new asgard
suggesting that king of valkyrie's rule over
that colony is struggling so we could see more
of in love and thunder the b-roll they show of
tower bridge shows none of the drones in the open
air or spider-man's heroics but just the moments
when he and mysterio were obscured in the tower
walkway as peter wrecked those drones showing
more obviously mysterious manipulations because
if they showed peter fighting those drones that
would hurt the narrative that team mysterio wanted
out there that it was peter controlling the drones
clever virgin cleary name seen on his badge is an
odd to agent albert cleary the dodc comptroller
in the comics photographs are taken of a photo of
ned and mj from homecoming as well as peter's iron
spider charging point all these cables plugged
into one outlet but you'll notice the armor itself
is missing we see tony's eateth glasses
from far from home that case just left
open showing how peter must see this every day as
a reminder of tony and it's on a stack of ps4 not
at all dumpster diving for old consoles and stuff
now during the interrogation peter where's his the
physics are theoretical but the fun is real shirt
that he wore when tony dropped him off back home
in homecoming agent cleary says nick fury has been
off planet for the last year what yes nick fury
and far from home was actually the skrull taylos
a storyline that we're probably gonna revisit in
secret invasion now i'm wondering if cleary but
the fact that he knows this could also be a scroll
clear he's able to get negan by tricking him into
correcting his misstatement when mj told you that
peter was spider-man what's up i knew way before
mj did i was spider-man's guy in the chair and a
fun detail here compared to mj's observation room
that you see in the reflection ned's room has way
more agents watching as they all know this is the
suspect who's going to squeal now the news good
detail that was set in 1999 when he dressed like
travolta and pulp fiction and then matt murdock
enters which we will all applaud for the standing
o that he deserves you guys hear that story about
our charlie cox snuck into a theater with his wife
to watch spider-man no way home and no one clapped
mcu movies ruined half the people left the theater
story was crazy ben affleck came in and
punched charlie face that's great thank you
but i love how the dialogue here is a total meta
commentary on the insanity of this moment peter
says what is happening because indeed charlie
cox matt murdock in the mcu does raise a lot of
questions about the canonicity of all the netflix
marvel series and charlie's first words are
that's great thank you because this is simply
great and i'm sure charlie is pretty grateful
for it or he was just wrapping up a phone call
and they wanted to cut to the chase a little
quicker you're two and a half hour spider-man
nope charlie cox improvised that exchange
he was all based on personal experience what
he was doing was imagine on the other line
was kevin feige he called him being like do you
want to be back in the mcu that's great thank
you daredevil reboot shirt now john favreau if
you remember played foggy nelson in the 2003 ben
affleck daredevil which charlie cox said he and
favreau tried to reference in a line that got cut
and there was a line i think it got cut i don't
think it made it in the final thing but there was
a line where he was trying to remember something
that happened and he and he he said yeah i i can't
remember what happened i'm a little foggy about
that behind peter is another newspaper he saw
on jameson's wall web of destruction showing
peter's damage at the staten island ferry and
the washington monument in homecoming and tower
bridge and far from home but matt murdock proves
he does have his daredevil reflexes hey but i
love how peter's hand was already ready there
to catch that brick because he has spider sense
and on that brick the person misspelled the word
believe as if refusing to write the word lie in
front of mysterio they move into happy's condo
alarm system yeah notice how may punches in the
right code on her first try probably because
happy's passcode was something like one two three
four pretty sad lapse in security that we learned
in far from home what's your password password now
what is your password password the word password
you're the head of security and your password is
password i don't feel good about it either we see
several of happy security badges calling back him
telling everyone to wear the matches in iron man
3 but he actually might have swiped a bunch on his
way out knowing that his clearance was going to be
revoked so he could have used someone else's badge
to steal all that stark tech notice how peter
carries all five of those heavy suitcases just a
cool little detail showing how strong the kid is
that is cool from the iron man films that
we saw him bickering with and homecoming
good yes yeah no no put that down that's worth
more than you or me but now he clearly just
misses tony you can also see his boxing mask and
gloves on the table from iron man 2. we saw iron
man 2. now in the credits of this movie they
shout out downton abbey which is a call back to
him loving downton abbey and iron man 3 but folks
do you never see it in the movie in our previous
breakdown we just pointed some random frame on the
shelf saying that was down to naby but it wasn't
so anyone else who has that in their video just
clearly watched ours and stole it from us anyway
shut up all out there's actually another one
later in the laundry area oh but now that stark
industries was shut down she'll be stealing
her crayons from applebee's like we did in
the background we hear the news you'll put the
captain american shield on the statue of liberty
that looks ridiculous delivery alone yeah details
throughout this movie foreshadow the statue of
liberty final act and how most people in new york
are against putting cap's shield on that statue
wait a minute do you remember that one no i mean
that must have been like really enhanced audio
or something like that or is that like one thing
they threw in there i think they put some stuff in
there oh maybe dang is that the new phase we're
headed to is every time the movie gets released
there's gonna be more it's like reverse george
lucas scenario where they add more interesting
things because yeah that was clean footage
and that enhancement sounded natural yeah
wow that line actually might have quickly cleared
some stuff up that i was never confused on and
just accepted it yeah they probably put the shield
up there the shield falling is what almost causes
mj to fall to her death and it's literally on that
shield where peter almost makes his worst decision
so really the people in new york were right
from the get-go this shield being added to the
statue's bad news subtle detail that's pretty
son of a hard boosted the iron man painting in
the style of the obama what poster from iron man
oh sweet nighttime security monitor you can also
see that he swiped the recreation of the cap
shield that tony and coulson had in that movie
when they facetime mj's reading maya angelou's
i know why the caged bird sings she always reads
celebrated progressive authors and on her wall
is that photo of her ned from homecoming also a
photo that she took of pigeons in venice and far
from home and the drawings she drew of peter and
coach wilson in homecoming oh i know i just
like coming here to sketch people in crisis
it's you betty brant says go get him tiger
which of course is mary jane's catchphrase
for peter in the comics and in the 2004
film go get him tiger a supporter screams
this is darnold aptly an actor in zendaya's long
time assistant also among that shouting we hear
i s zack cherry flip guy return for a vocal
cameo after we saw him in homecoming okay
can you hear him say do a flip
and after he returns something i caught that
the first time bus and chung chi should boy
cleve coming at you live on the bus do a flip the
martial arts has a youth so i'm going to try and
grade this fight as we're going flash thompson
shows off his memoir flashpoint it's titled a nod
of the dc comics major crossover event inside
we see the mural of scientists how it's been
expanded from just howard stark in previous films
and all the other famous real world scientists
include jim erskine as well as hank pym
and then if you look closely oh that is
george washington carver's head a shrunken ant-man
with a nearby pym particle vial mr harrington's
different man he's a scientist sure clearly
he photoshopped himself into but also on that
yearbook page under chess club is a photo of that
blip girl sue lorman mentioned and far from home
though it looks like she's given a different name
here flash's photo is wow good catch taken outside
so fancy and then all the cards in this display
actually lists famous spider-man comics writers
peter unmasked by j.m strzezinski that's a nod
to j michael scherzinski who wrote the peter
unmasked issue of the civil war comics also
wrote the famous one more day story line that
is based on t defalco or tom defalco k boussiek
for kurt busiek and p david or peter david oh
man spiderman comics writers as peter walks down
that spiderman movie loves spiderman right it's a
black and white film now i asked people on twitter
if they could identify this matthew on twitter
pointed out that this is the same cafeteria from
the movie love simon and although this scene is
not from love simon that movie did shoot in the
same atlanta high school as john watts shot these
spider-man movies so this is actually a side short
film that john watts shot on location oh cool
because before he directed the spider-man
movie he worked with a short film group
called waverly flams all those shorts you can
still find on youtube now on the roof graffiti
shows different spider-man co-creators you can
actually see that same stick catch the dick on the
beast truck throughout the movie but not that one
peter parker and his fighter minions his hypnotic
spider senses seduced joan watson now while peter
does not really have hypnosis powers this line
does foreshadow how in this movie the memory spell
wipes the memory and gaslights mj so in a way that
ends up happening as peter leans over to kiss him
yes as it does peter you guess as peter gets his
college rejection letters dummy reassembles the
lego death star set that peter and ned worked on
in homecoming but then at the end dummy breaks
it like ned did in that movie this parallels
the way the actual death star was destroyed
twice in the third movie the star wars trilogy
i love that parallel that just makes me so
happy i think that's my my favorite use of
all the other brands we owned by disney when i
saw hey it's like when ned dropped it but i love
the idea of john watts being like you know
we can also parallel the star wars trilogy
hey some fan out there came specifically for this
this is so deep as peter swoops down to mj's shop
his small silhouette in the sky shows that he
was in his iron spider suit at first and then
the nanobots retracted on its descent but i guess
he was still holding that acceptance letter all
the while so the bots had to like retract around
his pinch fingers but when he lands you can see
mysterio decals on both the lamppost and on the
nearby wall and there is another banner for that
statue of liberty renovation as peter approaches
the sanctum sanctorum on the mailbox on the right
is the graffiti name romania for john romita
another spider-man comics writer and then on
the inside one of the apprentices is played by
emily fong long-time marvel studios production
employee wong portals in from upstairs you can
actually see the mechanical crimson bands of
cedar act that strange tossed on kaecilius
hanging on the wall there wong i guess just
didn't feel like carrying his luggage downstairs
makes sense i would use sling rings for that too
now strange's mug reads oh for [ __ ] sake and
now that multiverse madness is bringing in fox
x-men later patrick stewart professor x it truly
is foreign that strange's world is heating up
he also wears a hoodie of his alma mater colombia
probably rubbing it in for peter for getting
rejected from all these elite schools and showing
how strange stays connected with this university
and can just talk to them something peter failed
to even consider trying peter says it's not about
me i mean this is really hurting a lot of people
peter actually unknowingly repeats the ancient
one's core lesson to strange in the 2016 film is
not about you and that is what makes strange want
to help peter wong warns strange about his
memory wipe spell called the runes of cough
call that spell travels the dark borders between
known and unknown reality it's too dangerous
we've used it for a lot less do you remember the
full moon party at comtaj no exactly indicating
strange has used this dangerous reality warping
spell before one of many violations that probably
led to the crisis of multiverse madness yeah you
reckless bastard which might be his way of saying
don't include me in the memory wipe spell so that
i can remember peter and you can see behind wong
is the kamatosh courtyard that he's returning to
now peter parker's seeking dr strange's help this
way to make everyone forget that he's spider-man
is a reference to the one more day storyline
which actually ends in a similar place with mj
and peter's best friend forgetting that he is
spider-man after asking strange to exclude mj
from the spell he then remembers ned oh my god
what is a net yeah strange then pulls out a chunk
of the magic to observe ned closely something he
doesn't do for the others maybe an indicator that
ned has the hidden sorcerer abilities and strange
can now see it here i i i said that in the last
breakdown you did dude new rockstars have been
watching your video yeah yeah yeah i'm the i'm
the guy in the chair there's sorrow in here
no one knows it all you're the new rock star
intelligent being living amongst ordinary humans
because i uh stopped the video last reaction to
point that out something that i pointed out that a
lot of other people pointed out too you originated
it though i originated no one else ever pointed
out yeah in fact during our first viewing of the
film you stopped you were like it's ned he just
gave him the powers just then it has magic happen
by a doctor strange day oh my god the spell's been
cast we missed all the dialogue what's going on
right now what's going on with this important
piece of information i was too busy telling you
my theory and that's how all our reviews get made
we're just saying our rotten tomatoes
yeah let's check it with that we're
good now when the sanctum shakes knocks
over an artifact in the lobby this is
the same delicate stupid thing that thor
knocks over in ragnarok then peter shouts
basically everyone that knew that i was spiderman
before should still know and the moment peter
gives us our rule by which the multiverse
men cross over right before strange sees the
purple silhouette of the lizard the building
that's strange oh cool over peter's shoulder
villains a hulking figure at first i thought
sandman but based on the muscle definition
i think this is actually venom who also crossed
over into the mcu only briefly during this event
and behind lizard you can start to see glowing
dots for dozens more just a hint right here early
in the movie that beyond these nearer crossovers
are even more multiversal threats strange says
you changed my spell six times five times they
disagreed but peter asked strange to exclude
mj and ned in may and happy and then everyone who
knew before that's five so strange actually might
have secretly adjusted the spell a sixth time to
exclude himself and wong because he loves peter
so much you know what also could have happened he
could have been so flustered by the situation that
he didn't either properly counted it was stead
they get in anger and just had a little bit of
a slip up and thought i don't know man that
that just doesn't seem plausible whatsoever
whatsoever later as peter glides down to
the bridge i like how he used his wingsuit
webbing again it retracts here but his heads-up
display reads edith offline since the dodc shut
down the whole edith network which is also why
the voice has changed now now when he retracts
his armor his suit underneath is wrinkled i
just love that little detail reflecting how
it was crammed up against his body actually
later in this day you can see how his blue
button up is also super wrinkled another cool
detail i like that he needs to hire his clothes
shadow on the side of the car just to match his
silhouettes oh dope wow love it love it it's idp
and as we were included by the enneagram book we
saw on peter's bedroom earlier rearrange these
you get the body spidey's plural a clue for the
multiple spideys in this movie 63 a5m 3 a nod to
the amazing spider-man number three in 1963 the
comic debut of doc ock who makes his mcu debut
in the scene the footage that the girl in the car
watches on her tablet is actually a delayed live
feed from the daily bugle helicopter you can see
peter waving at the camera on the tablet ah that
of december 28 1922. after peter's
rambling speech the mit woman responds
you didn't rehearse that did you peter yeah
it is this failure that later leads peter to
script out and rehearse what he wants to say
to mj in the final scene hockey is revealed
hi there peter hello there peter hola hello peter
elephant's you see how his claws glow red this is
how that film indicated when the claws were in
control and he asks what have you done with my
machine i don't know what you're talking about
i don't know what machine the power of the sun
in the palm of my hand calling back his line from
that film the power of the sun in the palm of my
hand when doc ock lifts the concrete cylinder
over him i love how john watts briefly frames
him directly down the barrel of that cylinder
really cool shot composition there and i like
how peter it's like a bond movie as the fight
progresses like he webs down one of his claws
and then right after he webs a second claw to the
car door to try to slow him down now really cool
detail here as peter suspends the suv over the
tracks i heard that fight was originally much much
longer and that there were some like previz
effects that involved doc hawk and goblin
clashing at first oh that would have been
actually fighting maybe they'll maybe they'll
show like a deleted pre-vis you know when they
show like here's the storyboards of what it
was supposed it's not full deleted scene have i
set you up for some good pause react commentary
absolutely thank you nailed it thank you i think
you nailed it there i was like oh got it alley-oop
yeah maybe they'll show that to us maybe down
the road would be cool i felt like that fight
could have gone on longer yeah it was too
short movies too short movies too short
necessary pausing
justify the video yeah aren't you glad you
clicked on in a wide shot of that bridge you
could see the name andrew graffiti on the bridge
column i'm pretty sure toby and andrew's names
appear everywhere in this movie really and a brief
shot back on the bridge another cool detail no one
else having escaped the license plate reads 6306
asm for the amazing spider-man number six in 1963
that was the debut of kurt connors the lizard
whom doctor strange is dealing with at this
moment in the sewers doc absorbs peter's nanotech
something that he's able to do thanks to oscorp's
nanotechnology i'm something of a scientist myself
i read all your research on nanotechnology really
brilliant i'd like to thank harry osborne
and ozcorp industries for providing it
that taught me so much it taught me so much right
there that it was set up in the previous films
and it totally flew over my head i was like isn't
that a koicky dink that is tentacles or just abs
meld with the nano technology like that yeah peter
doesn't have to do anything he thought ahead as if
i ever encounter nanotech i better be able to
absorb that right quick but no yes it's neat
to see but that actually is in line his tentacles
aren't but now technology i forgot about that but
that was just for the tritium i thought so too
but hey maybe he just always kept it on hand or
something i don't know eric you're always right
there's a there's connective tissue enough and
when doc ock tries to stab him peter's nanotech
shifts from his helmet to his chest and they mixed
in a little ping sound effects so we know doc
hawk didn't stab him just skewered his necktie
peter's able to pair his os with doc
ock's arms since doc ock's arms are
controlled via neural link these smart arms are
controlled by my brain through a neural link
nanowires feed directly into
my cerebellum and otto stands
now in the undercroft there are actually a
total of six cells eventually filled by the five
multiverse men of this movie plus one more that is
filled by the tree that peter accidentally catches
six means that strange anticipated catching venom
as well and you can see how strange his face is
scratched now since he had just fought the lizard
doc asks what is this a birthday party calling
back tony stark referencing strange's jimmy kimmel
bit when they first met what is your job exactly
besides making balloon animals around the falling
sanctum you can see various pages from spell books
have been pinned up on lamps to dry out never a
good idea to rip out pages from spell books folks
downstairs is a creepy doll that turns them they
know what they're doing tick tock is a cosplayer
dressed as a green elf looking just like tom
holland's character in pixar's onwards oh
[ __ ] that's easter egg peter tracks down electro
and sandman same man helping peter because they
were on good terms at the end of the 2007 film
now one shot shows peter pulling together multiple
strands to beat electro mirrored from what he
did you're doing this to beat the electro in this
nice when electro and sandman get trapped in
the cells in the foreground you can see the
control panel showing five lit up icons for
each cell the fifth one lit up for the tree
there is a sixth unlit button for the cell that
will soon be occupied by norman i'm telling you
one of these cells was going to be for venom
i mean i know that there was a deleted scene
that they didn't do with venom that were supposed
to come into the finale but i do wonder if like
something with that was going on in the world some
virus that was specific think of anything might
have caused issues with that actually happening
right i don't know the best conclusion you could
draw i guess so that's probably the only thing i
could think of all the parameters they were able
to work around not that one got to keep tom hardy
healthy not that one uh keep him sick protect tom
hardy i think it's because this was the first
ever anti-back set yes and tom hardy was like
i'm not going on your set unless everyone's
fixed eddie we need to get our pfizer
i will not eat mrs chen until she gets her
booster norman osborne shatters his goblin mask
the framing in the alley matches the framing
of toby peter leaving his suit behind in the
2004 film but in both cases those characters get
dragged back into the game but it is interesting
to note that goblin goes straight back aunt may
because assuming he was transported from the rainy
verse right after learning peter was spider-man
at thanksgiving sometime around that scene when he
similarly cowered in front of the mask in his home
his next move there was to go for the heart which
in that movie was also ant-may the feast billboard
tagged with mysterio was right actually is a word
bubble that says meet queen's own spider-man uh
i don't know about you guys did you notice it
uh oh you mean the big graffiti of him with the
mysterio on his head or maybe he was just a nope
anti-spider-man i definitely noticed
whatever it is you're talking about though
to me that looks like the symbol from the x-men
it does and they've already referenced for [ __ ]
sake once i'm telling you vos just watches our
reactions and he's gonna put this in his follow
up right now i found one more detail whole break
that does not mean stop or cancel this man that's
clearly an x-ray i mean yeah it's kind of hard
to deny that circle and an x it's pretty simple
in fact that's why a lot of people didn't
attend xavier school for the gifted because
the x symbols everywhere confuse the [ __ ]
out of me this is not a welcoming environment
inside norman wears a green coat and purple sweats
his colors in the comics but also this is stuff he
clearly got from the donation bin meaning
that he walked into this facility wearing
his goblin suit but aunt may still wanted to
help him he says someone's living in my house
oscar doesn't exist yes oscorp does not exist
in the mcu making it likelier that peter's
spider bite might have come from stark tech
i made a whole video about that check it out
it may mean while i was wearing a blue
jumpsuit with a red sash throughout this
movie she's almost always wearing spider-man's
red and blue colors goblins background signaling
he's still in his shifty goblin survival mode
actually and peter says he's shaking doughnuts
not your problem calling back toby's line in the
2002 film that led to uncle ben's death i missed
the part where that's my problem jay jonah
jameson's chiron reads why does spider-man
hate national landmarks showing the washington
monument in the tower bridge now if you look
closely you can see that peace truck actually
used to be for the forest hills moving company
queens is historically peter parker's
neighborhood strange shows them the
machina cadavers its name coming from the crystal
of cadavers in the comics used to try to resurrect
the dead in a strange spider-man team-up issue
in this case it will doom these men to their
deaths to make them literal cadavers strange
pushes peter's soul out of his body but peter
is able to use his spider sense to control his
limbs wavy lines stretch out from his head which
strange throws a cloak of levitation around peter
giving us the caped spider-man that we saw in the
what if comics and in episode five of what if now
on the newsstand is the people magazine interview
with liz allen from homecoming he's a liar which
i assume is a defense piece for her father adrian
tomb since peter got him arrested something maybe
we could revisit morbius but i like all this
probably not definitely passed with parker despite
these two never actually kissed in homecoming it
was in the trailer but not in the final cut of the
movie so really this whole article is a distortion
in the mirror dimension peter tumbles down the
high line of manhattan and he passes a billboard
showing a t-rex skeleton it's an interesting
parallel to strange's coming multiverse tumbling
past on the train dr strange's eye of agamotto
briefly opens and illuminates showing that this
artifact still has some power beyond being a
mere time stone fanny pack something else that
we will see in multiverse madness peter uses
the geometry of archimedean spirals to string
up strange shortly after strange mentioned
the grand calculus of the multiverse geometry
versus calculus just showing how peter used the
simpler math to defeat his overthinking rival
norman says the line you know i'm something
of a scientist myself peter and ed did their
handshake from homecoming but now ned
produces a spark out of that sling ring
peter takes them all into happy's condo
actually deleted scene would have shown
them in the elevator together bummed we missed
out on that on the way in we see them on the
security monitor elektra causes some distortion
on the feed and then he uses his hand to zap the
tv on where we see a news poll on that statue
of liberty renovation showing 67 percent of new
yorkers disapprove of it love how there's this
whole like subplot about that damn shield being
built there i'm against it personally personally
i think it ruins a historical landmark mm-hmm
how did the french feel about that who cares
what the french think america owns it that's true
they get night monkey that's enough i'm surprised
so many new yorkers did not approve of that though
actually as a detail like the fact that everything
about that has been people being opposed to it is
actually a surprise i feel like people would be
down for a captain america shield but the falcons
now captain america that's true black falcon
that's black properly black cap yeah black
captain america they need to put a black shield
on the stage i think we got the right messages
definitely a falcon of winners yorkers are racist
yeah but we're not but not us we just make jokes
perpetuating the wrists black jokes on the wall
and happy's back room is the name slots for dance
lot another big spider-man comics writer that
stark fabricator is the same kind of machine
that peter used to 3d print his new suit on the
jet and far from home and it is powered by the
specific era of the arc reactor in iron man 2
when it had that triangular inlay tony stark
later replaced this with new versions showing
why these old ones would be stored may and doc
och briefly connect in the kitchen and not to
them getting married at one point in the comics
morgan stark reminding him of his daughter penny
who would be around the same age peter plugs in
the new inhibitor chip to dock the claw lights go
from red to white as they did in the 2004 film to
indicate auto regaining control and notice on
the fabricator peter created profiles for each
of his patients c connors m dylan and osborne but
only max's cure is listed as complete since as we
see later when mei tries to plug norman with
the antidote it does not work otto chats with
norman how does it feel norman you're about
to become whole again no more darker half
just you just me yes defoe uses his darker goblin
voice there teasing the goblin is about to make
his move also notice as he turns around he is
suddenly sweating bullets despite not sweating
that much seconds before this yeah i gotta tell
you guys to this day when i see this footage
it blows my mind i mean we gotta meet willem
dafoe at the premiere thanks to koi zhandra who
always wants a shout out whenever we mention that
seeing him up close he looks way older he does he
does looks significantly older yes i was like a
shake a hand but i don't want to break you yeah
i'm like you look so non-threatening and i feel
like you look so sweet do you need me to hold your
hair you can help across the road my dude i'm
surprised you volunteered for all those stunts
the camera adds like six inches to your
height as well as whatever weight it puts on
all right guys you're gonna see some cats coming
in and out of here for a while because they're
hungry peter's spider sense activates again like
we saw on the bridge we get another great dolly
zoom camera move now behind him on the left here
is actually howard stark's expo bottle from iron
man 2 but the first person peter passes and his
trance is norman the source of the danger the
camera only pulls away from peter when may enters
the frame and she's burning sage and she says
what is it it starts with blends the space
sage doesn't work can't just like yeah
raised to wed norman it only goes back down
when sandman asks what's happening distracting
peter over on the right and in that moment of
distraction norman moves across the room to
dummy which even doc ock abuses suspicious based
off his expression after peter whips him goblin
reveals himself these are not curses they're gifts
gifts and curses a call back to the 2002 film line
this is my gift my curse also notice how devoe
now shows the gap in his teeth which he did not
have when he smiled before because in the 2000s
as norman osborne but shifted to his normal teeth
when he transformed into goblins really happy i
always what he noticed his teeth in that scene
but i'd never do that in there profile that was
crazy more and more as peter punches him showing
how each hit makes him stronger and crazier so
goblin hits may with his glider and bombs the
place on his way out he slices the daily bugle
van telecom tower which actually does james in
a favor because in his really shitty broadcast
after this incident he's able to lie and say that
this was all spider-man's doing not goblins and
then may drops the big adage and with great power
there must also come more responsibility great
damn it you got a lot to keep track of with your
power must also come from amazing fantasy 15 when
stan lee spoke at his exposition you can actually
see this quote on marissa tomes title card in
the closing credits oh she dies peter says okay
it's just me and you calling back when may said
this to peter and homecoming just laying it out
it's just me and you which i read as may referring
to ben's recent death it was just the two of them
then and just the two of them now now in ned's
nana's house they also have that photo of ned
and mj from homecoming showing how all three of
these friends had a different copy of this and we
see it now because ned and mj really just want to
be with peter i think all this was intended to be
a back to the future photo style prop to show how
these two did have a version of their life without
peter in it now lola also has a sewing machine
but just to be clear this is a different sewing
machine than the one peter has at the end of
the film we don't know that he stole it we don't
know that yeah i've seen heavy spoilers thumbnail
yeah it's all coming down to that sewing machine
or he swapped it out with something else it's the
same sewing machine there's that partner's defeat
yeah stealing from old ladies i'm still not
over that teeth thing that is crazy i yeah
i'd never do that that is a crazy little detail
that is now endured for like 20 odd more years
i'm gonna do watch this performance that was
look at his teeth look at that what are his teeth
regular one or his teeth now noticeably perfect
like a dog showing its fangs it does make his
face look a little different though now that he
points it out yeah yeah it's like that's how he
gets a goblin face with his natural teeth
andrew garfield spider-man enters the film
string theory multi-dimensional reality and matter
displacement all real interracial friends yeah
what's under there is actually james corner's
amazing spider-man theme i just love the meta
wordplay between andrew and mj why do i need to
crawl around because this is not enough this is
plenty no it's not yes it is no it's not it
is oh yeah as if one past spider-man is not
enough which mj doubles down on yeah i guess you
just keep doing until we find the real one ouch
now when andrew hops down from the ceiling the
sling ring portal has now pivoted to face him
turning on its axis from the direction it was
facing before just showing how ned opened this
portal in order to find peter and so peter is
how the portal orients itself in the room then
great it's just some random guy
and after teaching peter some critical
lessons about dealing with these groups
the three peters rally to and engineer
okay so uh connors marco dylan and um
yes he cannot bring himself to say osborne's
name because deep down he doesn't want to cure
him yet which toby double checks i think
i can make an anti-serum for dr osborne
i've been thinking about it a long time gotta cure
all of them right i also like the implication that
toby has been losing sleep over wishing he could
have cured osborne over all these years instead
of watching them die and when toby talks about
harry osborne watch andrew here do you have a
best friend too yeah i've always noticed that you
did he died in my arms after he tried to kill me
andrew goes from pity for toby's friend in his
arms to surprise and empathy for his harry also
trying to kill him he's just always trying to
take attention away isn't he that andrew garfield
oh he's just so living in the character he's the
guy on twitter writing all the three hashtags
this whole time just trying to get back on screen
and we get the meme peter yeah oh sorry sorry
yeah they all point at each other which even the
movie script directs as memes when tony webb's a
stool notice he still has his scars on his wrist
from the remy films and again andrew's reaction
is the best you can't do that huh no how on earth
does that even anyway we're getting sidetracked
look this is what we're gonna do yeah it takes
him a solid beat for andrew to finally take his
eyes off that scar andrew cracks toby's back less
deadly than what he did to gwyn orwell fighting
venom and spider-man 3 and thanos and rhino and
the amazing spider-man 2 and toby says but it's
just a self-talk maybe we should listen though
because you're you're amazing just to take it in
for a minute yeah yeah yeah you are amazing then
electro appears and the bolts form the shape of
electro's classic mask from the comics on his face
you actually see this shape again later when he's
zapping andrew ned is unable to close his portal
and that might be because the other two times he
opened the portal the purpose he was seeking
to find peter was met so those portals closed
on their own but now ned's real purpose deep down
is to help this battle he can't take his mind off
the battle and allow that portal to close at first
the three peters okay that makes a lot more sense
in the face magic is mental gross yeah toby says
gross despite andrew's webbing being artificial
unlike his webbing that comes out of his body
tom says i was in the avengers the avengers yeah
that's great thank you what is that oh you don't
have the avengers is that a bad are you the band
calling back how bruce compared the avengers to
the beatles in infinity war like a band like like
the beatles and then when they leap each peter's
jump is unique to his respective era toby does
a double front flip tom does a frog pose oh that
is beautiful he's just so beautiful he's an under
the legs whip as he would his movies and then tom
turns around to web his two brothers to sling them
along with him and when he does this he uses the
side roll move that cap did when he was fighting
yes i never thought of that toby first andrew
second tom third now during the battle andrew
webbs up the lizard to restrain him but it
takes a while for the lizard to break out of it
compared to the 2012 movie when lizard was
able to tear out of the webbing seconds later
might be showing how andrew spent these years
strengthening his webbing after you know there you
film go is able to restrain electro since his
claws were designed to be impervious to energy
spikes and then after notice how toby is holding
his chest because unlike andrew his suit was not
designed to be shock proof ned finally brings
doctor strange back i've been dangling over the
grand canyon for 12. i know i know in a way this
is a bit of payback for strange making loki free
fall for a half hour i have been falling for 30
minutes goblin shouts can the spiderman come out
calling back his line in the 2002 film can
spiderman come out to play now when strange
lassoes the box and pulls it away you can
see goblin with both hands on the box smiling
because he just slipped in that pumpkin bomb he
cuts one of dockhawk's arms and leaves them with
the explosion caused mj to fall from the
scaffolding framing her just like gwen's
death drop except here turn on the side and
andrew retakes the plunge except this time
instead of honestly yeah we're emotional again
jesus christ leave it in this one as peter
puts norman on that shield he leaps up at one
point and punches down denting the metal yeah
which totally would have caved in his skull
that always stuck with me we're gonna stab him
with it the same way goblin died in the 2002 film
but also evoking bringing down the shield on tony
in civil war a parallel that's even more obvious
since they are fighting upon cap's shield but
toby stops tom from killing goblin no words just
doesn't want the kid to grow rageful and bitter
but goblin stabs him and tom literally turns his
body from one side to the other he was in killing
mode but now he turns the cheek andrew sees this
hey nice catch nice throttle toby's
okay saying yeah i'm gonna step oh god
the morning when harry osborn stabbed him in
the rainy films purple cracks in the sky open
up i've broken this down before but the visible
silhouettes include madame webb getting her own
movie the superior spider-man armor with multiple
arms craving the hunter getting his own movie
scorpion the original comics form black cat and
then later rhino and then i figure everyone keeps
calling mysterio based off of the head but i don't
think so this guy walks with more of a timid step
and has a slender build i think this is actually
miles morales peter tells strange to go through he
looks more like him goodbye to each other thank
you sir call me stephen thank you steven yeah
still feels weird calling back their banter of
course earlier in this movie but also the very
first time they met an infinity war and joked
about their real names i'm peter by the way
doctor strange oh using their made up names um
i'm spider-man then peter hugs the other peters
thank you thank you thank you thank you a hug
that was improvised by tom holland to thank these
past two eras of spiderman so after the spell goes
through peter returns to the peter pan donut shop
a name with greater significance now for a peter
who has to watch others through her window living
their lives without him mj oh wow yeah that's the
truth who must now grow up i suppose this is meant
to be the film's stan lee cameo but really just
to make us do a double take and evoke deja vu the
way mj feels in the scene the script also states
that mj is meant to watch peter go with quote a
lingering sense of recognition this plus the fact
that she is still wearing that broken black dahlia
necklace tells us that some part of her still
remembers peter it made or she likes the necklace
which could be a nod to tony stark always
questioning how young she really is back
in civil war and the quote reads when you help
someone you help everyone which is actually what
is written on her grave in the spider-man ps4 game
in the envelope peter moves into a new apartment
is due on the first of the month don't be late
yes his squalor apartment evokes peter's crappy
flat in the rainy films and while the landlord's
voice is the fact that he reminds peter the rant
is definitely meant to remind us of that guy
we see that peter is studying for the ged
meaning peter's academic records must have been
wiped or warped since if you think about it much
of his midtown high identity was really wrapped
up in his spider-man identity at this point i
did do another video breaking down how exactly
reality was worked and who remembers what i highly
recommend you check it out on peter's table is the
we are happy to serve you cup that mj gave peter
in the cafe and by the way that coffee cup is just
a generic new york area coffee cup that appears in
productions of literally everything shot in that
city it's not a retreat they exist in real life
this cup isn't everything it's like saying i saw
one just the other day what is the cool detail
peter has that lego palpatine figurine which was
the first line we heard spoken by ned in this
trilogy in homecoming and peter has a new song
oh that's good let's stitch together diy finally
without having avengers to build his tech for him
and design wise it's made of a brighter fabric
clearly inspired by the designs of the other two
spider-men actually the closing credits show his
sketches of a new logo as he swings through
rockefeller's center failing to make a cameo
in the final battle of hawkeye we get this awesome
closing frame almost a jump scare because he zooms
it right in on our faces giving us an extreme
close-up of his new mask but up close like this we
can see it is textured in a porous fabric gone are
those mechanical eyepieces this is just a cloth
mask yes a new beginning a fresh start baby that
is everything i spotted in this high residential
release of no way home but folks there is still
the 4k version coming next month and there's
going to be a lot of deleted scenes commentary
lots of bonus footage gives me a lot of time
600 miss details again so be sure to subscribe to
new rockstars you can follow me on instagram break
down the post credits subscribe to support this
channel directly thank you so much for watching
bye what did you notice in the venom yeah and
how to tie into when he was supposed to be at the
statue of liberty was that guy really mexican is
that guy the same guy from ted lasso daniel rojas
new rock stars you crazy sons of [ __ ] thanks for
putting this together eric voss you are the boss
boss boss boss voss haven't
caught that wild kingping
anyway king Vboss
that was good i was that big man i was
seriously epic congratulations not to work
a lot of work from all you editors eric you're
all beautiful people say hi to your mother for me